servus und herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video heute spielen wir seit
langer langer zeit mal wieder gut es
geht mit dem einzigartigen doktor med
und ich werde es aus der map sind in
einer legendären runde bestehend aus 100
spieler locker 100 watt ab jahrhundert
kommt hinhalten klar die ta reporter ist
dass die wasser der sulipo hat der
berner gesagt ihm aber junge youtube ist
auch ein vorbild sein
grüßt mich erst mal aus mit 1000 gästen
und danach keine kills nano eines toten
king power aber ich krieg verhindern
weil ich habe natürlich den angreifen
der mich angreift ist ja kein team ich
sehe euch die kannst du jetzt mal ja
nichts gegen die rallye sehr bitter
wieviel leben hat diese junge wächst des
todes es gibt keine rodnei der taliban
hat abgestoppt ok junge wie krass das
wahlalter wieder habe ich das gefühl und
den daumen zu kriegen war der gott zu
mir ich immer gerne alles ist
wir sind die letzten worte machen das
machen
okay aber durch den sie kriegen h sollen
wir eigentlich schon mal anti sind was
wir gerade ihm besprochen haben wir das
mal an dieser sehr spontan
es ist sehr spontan leute ich will auch
gar nicht zu viel sagen das match 28
sekunden ich nutze die zeit um was
anzubieten und zwar hatten der ben und
ich so eine idee wie erzählt man uns
davon ohne zu viel zu verraten also ist
sicher spannend durch bestimmt gefallen
oder sogar dass wir ein duell
wann wird es wohl eine serie starten
aber keine normale serie sondern auf
einem eigenen server und unter
besonderen bedingungen
mal und zwar haben diese bedingungen
fünf buchstaben a c k s
axel haasis das heißt wir haben vor
eventuell ein ein hack duell zu starten
was es war weil wir ganz klar betont
dass wir nur auf privaten servern hacken
auf public servern hacken ist absolut
verboten wo quasi jeder in jeder folge
neuen heck zugelost bekommt und dann
beispielsweise wenn jesus klickt und ich
krieg face no klippen könnte ich wende
gehen er kann über wasser gehen und dann
spielen wir quasi immer mit diesen hexen
wir gucken so verdi am besten ausspielen
kann so schreibt man die kommentare was
er davon halten würde so die chance
liegt dass man das natürlich nur auf
privaten macht und wir das auf public
überhaupt nicht zu stützen sondern
verbieten und ganz arg bahn ja ok amanda
zumal die kommentare kassen müssen wir
waren drei haben hier ja und jetzt würde
ich sagen mein lieber benson
lasst uns mal liefen liefen einfach das
leben hat er den bogen gespannt hat der
etwa ein bogen gespannt ob er den fall
jetzt hast du den bogen überspannt
meiner reife jeder schutz setzt pro
gamer er ist counter strike pro gamer ja
wir die angel combo raus da silva der
sein gold abgesehen hat ja nein sondern
hat aber wie gesagt dass opel verboten
sind nein kleine stinker ihr heil der
sich ein
das hat aber wiegelt haben ich nenne das
ging ganz gut hat mir nicht wehgetan hat
gar nicht wehgetan
böhmer seehofer
marc gini
du okay leute nächste runde
willkommen zur zweiten runde so ich habe
direkt ein erster ich habe einen bogen
hcd
was willst du nicht mehr vorne wartete
wurde
wir haben jetzt halt dafür dadurch dass
es so ein bisschen später ist jetzt 12
oder so haben die ganzen runden für uns
heißt easy skins easy life wenn das so
krass in minecraft so spät ist es ja
jetzt gar nicht so spielen wie cod oder
counterstrike merkt man das gar nicht
das spielt das weiter zocken dann halt
weil der wert soll die europäer weniger
aber es gibt dann der amis du warst
unser gegner so aber gemeinschaft
deutschen da gibt's natürlich keine amis
wobei ich hatte auf dem manara war oder
sie sowas ja da war ich dabei der süße
wäre schon ein bisschen komisch
die gleichen sachen der dadurch die
sniper heute hab ich nicht okay neue
strategie deeskalation einfach in die
luft streckt ja wenn diesmal wird nicht
funktionieren dass ich hinterher laufe
und durch sein kannst ja ich hasse leute
die das machen
also du es nicht machen würdest du heute
schwer
bitte ein herz bis war auf vier
trainingseinheiten für bmw war das
erinnert an dieses london wahrnahm ein
episches comeback ich habe mich schon
abgeschrieben war ja immer die
konzentration flöten wenn ich 4 1 vorne
liege und einen cameo pokalsieger vielen
oder so richtig übel
die erste ging an die sich für eins
gemacht und dann hat er bei mir in den
kommentaren ein hier oben verlinkt
übrigens leute ja ich hatte bei mir
einen konter bordeaux war das total von
ascot zerstört und nicht so ausgebrannt
also ich hab noch bis 40 gesehen ja gut
aber da war ja eine runde die wir
zurückgezogen haben ja gewöhnt haben
wohl einige leute an kommentiert die
rundeten damit hab ich das ding 5 1 klar
dass beide zuschauersaal des matches das
war deine die haben alle geschrieben
hätte ich bin fan von fairbanks im jahr
wahrscheinlich da die das fließen also
in eppelheim diesen doktor banks ist
cool aber er ist es besser in pvp 1 2
und 3 nicht dass so lange nahm auf
youtube sind min doch doch die haben
youtube direkt mit ihnen mit respekt
youtube explodiert das war's mit diesem
sehr chaotischen absolut sinnfreien
video einem schreiben eure meinung zu
dem vorschlag aus der ersten runde ein
wir sind bei der nächsten folge wieder
drei macht's gut